hi I'm sanjana Reddy a machine learning
engineer at Google's Advanced Solutions
lab
there's a lot of excitement currently
around generative Ai and new
advancements including new vertex AI
features such as gen AI Studio model
Garden gen AI API our objective in this
short session is to give you a solid
footing on some of the underlying
Concepts that make all the Gen AI magic
possible
today I'm going to talk about the
attention mechanism that is behind all
the Transformer models and which is core
to the llm models
let's say you want to translate an
English sentence the cat ate the mouse
to French
you could use an encoder decoder this is
a popular model that is used to
translate sentences the encoder decoder
takes one word at a time and translates
it at each time step however sometimes
the words in the source language do not
align with the words in the target
language here's an example take the
sentence black cat ate the mouse
in this example the first English word
is black
however in the translation the first
French word is she which means cat in
English
so how can you train a model to focus
more on the word cat instead of the word
black at the first time step
to improve the translation you can add
what is called the attention mechanism
to the encoder decoder
attention mechanism is a technique that
allows the neural network to focus on
specific parts of an input sequence
this is done by assigning weights to
different parts of the input sequence
with the most important parts receiving
the highest weights
this is what a traditional RNN based
encoder decoder looks like the model
takes one word at a time as input
updates the hidden State and passes it
on to the next time step
in the end only the final hidden state
is passed on to the decoder
the decoder works with the final hidden
state for processing and translates it
to the target language
an attention model differs from the
traditional sequence to sequence model
in two ways first the encoder passes a
lot more data to the decoder
so instead of just passing the final
hidden state number three to the decoder
the encoder passes all the hidden States
from each time step
this gives the decoder more context
Beyond just the final hidden state
the decoder uses all the hidden State
information to translate the sentence
the second change that the attention
mechanism brings is adding an extra step
to the attention decoder before
producing its output
let's take a look at what these steps
are
to focus only on the most relevant parts
of the input the decoder does The
Following
first it looks at the set of encoder
states that it has received
each encoder hidden state is associated
with a certain word in the input
sentence second it gives each hidden
State a score
third it multiplies each hidden state by
its soft Max score as shown here
thus amplifying hidden states with the
highest scores
and downsizing hidden states with low
scores
if we connect all of these pieces
together we're going to see how the
attention network works
before moving on let's define some of
the notations on this slide
Alpha here represents the attention
weight at each time step H represents
the hidden state of the encoder RNN at
each time step
H subscript D represents the hidden
state of the decoder RNN at each time
step
with the attention mechanism the
inversion of the black cat translation
is clearly visible in the attention
diagram
an 8 translates as two words image and
French we can see the attention Network
staying focused on the word eight for
two time steps
during the attention step we use the
encoder hidden States and the H4 Vector
to calculate a context Vector A4 for
this time step this is the weighted sum
we then concatenate H4 and A4 into one
vector
this concatenated Vector is passed
through a feed-forward neural network
one trained jointly with the model to
predict the next word
the output of the feed forward neural
network indicates the output word of
this time step this process continues
till the end of sentence token is
generated by the decoder this is how you
can use an attention mechanism to
improve the performance of a traditional
encoder decoder architecture
thank you so much for listening